[موسيقى]
تشهد مكه المكرمه خلال شهر رمضان توافد
اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين من مختلف انحاء
العالم وسط توقعات بارتفاع مؤشرات الايواء
والفنادق في مكه المكرمه خلال هذه الفتره
بنحو مئه في المئه نظرا لتزايد اعداد
الزوار والمعتبرين الذين يتوافدون على مكه
المكرمه وتحتضن مكه المكرمه اكثر من الف
فندق واكثر من 250 الف غرفه فندقيه
بتصنيف عالي الجوده اذا وحسب المواصفات
العالميه وهي جاهزه لاستقبال المعتبرين
المعتمرين وكذلك جميع هذه الفنادق ملتزمه
وتقوم بعمليه التنظيف والتعقيم لكافه
المرافق على مدار الساعه
مباشره من الحرم المكي معنا اسامه القاسم
مراسل العربيه اسامه من خلفك يعني حشود
كبيره من المعتمرين في الشهر الفضيل هل
لدينا بدايه اي ارقام او احصائيات عن
اعداد ضيوف الرحمن على الاقل في العشر
الاوائل من رمضان
[موسيقى]
اهلا صهيب تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع مشاهدي
قناه العربيه وطاب مسائكم بكل خير نعم
بالامس رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اعلنت عن وصول
اكثر من 9.4 مليون زائر ومعتمر الحرم
المكي خلال العشر الاوائل وبالتاكيد ان
هذه الاعداد سوف تتضاعف مع الايام القادمه
حتى انتهاء شهر رمضان المبارك طبعا
الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين بالتعاون مع عدد من
الجهات تقدم الخدمات الكبيره جدا للزوار
والمعتمرين داخل اروقه المسجد الحرام ايضا
بمساحه البارح كان هناك اكثر من 12 مليون
لتر من سقيا زمزم تم توزيعها وايضا اكثر
من زائر ومعتمر للمسجد الحرام طبعا هذه
الصوره التي نشاهدها الان هي اثناء اداء
صلاه التراويح في مسجد الحرام والتي
نشاهدها الان في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
وساحات التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه ايضا
بالامس تم اعلان استكمال تهيئه جميع مرافق
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بما فيها
الساحات والاسطح كذلك ونعم صهيب ايضا
اليوم تشهد امتلاء بالكامل هناك اكثر من
الف فندق في مكه المكرمه باكثر من 250 الف
وحده سكنيه وترتكز هذه الفنادق في الششه
العزيزيه ومحبس الجن وايضا المسفله التي
الان هي ممتلئه بالكامل ولكن اسامه هذا
المشهد الذي كنا نتابعه الان للمصلين وهم
يؤدون صلاه التراويح هذه الاعداد الغفيره
كيف يتم تسيير خروجهم بعد اتمام الصلاه
يعني اعداد كبيره جدا كيف يتم تفادي وقوع
الازدحامات
[موسيقى]
نعم صحيح كل هذه الاعداد التي نشاهدها
الان وكل هذه الحشود يتم اخراجها او
ادخالها بطريقه معينه من خلال توفير عدد
من الكوادر الامنيه المدنيه وايضا عدد من
المترجمين لارشاد التائهين وايضا الجهات
الامنيه المشاركه كامن الحج والعمره
والامن العام طبعا هناك طريقه دائما تحصل
في شهر رمضان المبارك هي ان كل توسعه وكل
ساحه لها مدخل ولها مخرج هذه المداخل
والمخارج تقلق وقت الصلاه لاداء الصلوات
سواء صلاه التراويح او الصلوات الاخرى
وتفتح بعد انتهاء الصلوات ويكون هناك حركه
تردديه في الدسمه والخروج الجدير بالذكر
ايضا ان هناك اربع محطات متواجده حول
الحرم المكي لايصال الزوار والمعتمرين الى
فنادقهم والاتيان بهم ايضا الى الحرم
اسامه اكثر من تسعه ملايين
مكه المكرمه في العشر الاوائل من رمضان ما
هي التوقعات للعشر الاواخر التي تحظى
بقدسيه كبيره لدى المسلمين
[موسيقى]
نعم صهيب بالتاكيد العشر الاواخر تحظى
بهذه القدسيه الكبيره جدا نتحدث عن
بالتاكيد ان هناك ستكون اعداد كبيره لم
نصل الى احصائيه معينه ولكن بالتاكيد انها
ستكون ضعف ما احصيه خلال العشر الاولى
العشر الاواخر ايضا هناك خطط مختلفه
بالنسبه للتنظيم لكثره الحشود وكثره
الزوار والمعتمرين وايضا ان الحركه تكون
مرتكزه بشكل كبير جدا حول مساحه المطاف
والمسحه وتاكيد سيكون هناك تركيز اعلى من
خلال تفويج واداره حشود زوار ومعتمرين
المسجد الحرام الفنادق ممتلئه الان هل
سيكون هناك مساحه مثلا في الايام القادمه
يعني هذا ما سيكون ايضا سنعلمه في الايام
القادمه صهيب هناك اكثر من 350 شركه
لاداء العمره مجهزه بالكامل هي بالتاكيد
انها تسعى ايضا انها تعمل موازنه وتحاول
انها ما تكون في ازدحام في خلال هذه شكرا
من الايام القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الصوره الحيه مباشره من الحرم المكي
الشريف اسامه القاسم مراسل العربيه